welcome to the day last week u.s
president joe
biden released an intelligence report
identifying saudi arabia's ruler
as the man who sanctioned the brutal
murder of saudi dissident
and u.s resident jamal khashoggi but mr
biden decided that the diplomatic cost
of directly punishing crown prince
mohammed bin salman was too high
this despite describing saudi arabia
during his election campaign
as a pariah state with no redeeming
value
well mr khashoggi's fiance isn't giving
up she's now at the center of legal
battles
from turkey to the us and germany to
bring his killers to justice
it's a state killing and as such
it is important that the state of saudi
arabia be held accountable
historically the united states through
democratic and republican presidents has
not typically
sanctioned government leaders of
countries where we have
diplomatic relations so far the
government of the united states
has not announced any actions
uh to build on their findings of
a liability and responsibility on the
part of the crown prince mohammed bin
salman
it is extremely um in my view
problematic we're going to make sure
that they in fact
you know if they want to deal with us
they have to deal with it in a way that
human rights abuses are dealt to fiancee
hatija
jaingidis joins us now from istanbul
welcome to dw
last week president biden released a u.s
intelligence report into jamal's killing
it concluded that crown prince mohammed
approved
the murder but then the u.s government
imposed no sanctions against the prince
what did you think when you heard that
i think that it is a very significant
moment why they did but i don't
also i think it is not enough
without any sanction or taking
any step against the criminals and
they already released the report without
getting any action
what it is meaning or it is meaning
um it does not mean anything for me
what should joe biden do about this
the truth is now clear more than
any any time
and he can do more he can
do take an action against the criminals
included crown friends
saudi arabia has convicted eight people
over
jamal's killing they've sentenced five
of them to death
was that justice
i don't think so because we did not
heard about any trial
openly or publicly we don't have any
information about these people and what
they did
why why they killed jamal and what is
his body
there is no answers all our questions
and and they they did not
uh publicly and openly their trial they
did not share with the
the people with the media and the world
and there is no any real evidence to to
believe them
right there's a trial at the moment in
turkey
26 saudis being tried in turkey over
jamal's murder
even though saudi arabia is refusing to
extradite the suspects
what do you hope to come out of the
trial in turkey
what's happening in turkey it's
according to turkish law
it goes uh the on the right way
and we me and my my lawyers um
we are following this uh this case in
turkey
and what turkey did from the beginning
and announce the truth to the world
and share the evidence with the words
and now what goes in turkey it's uh
according to turkish law as i told you
now
so um this the third station
just happened yesterday and um
follow the case right
you're also suing uh the crown prince in
a u.s
uh court um what does it feel like
fighting such a powerful man
it is uh actually it wasn't my
uh personal choice why
why uh when they killed jamal
uh i think it it it's it's like
kind of um part of love
and i i feel that i should
i should ask more because i lost my
my my my husband my my my friend
and my uh he was everything for me in
that time
and um i i i i felt a big responsibility
on my shoulder
so i couldn't choose any way just this
way seeking justice for jamal
and and and and for his soul
and for his principles that we
already were sharing the same uh
vision and mission and it's time to ask
or respect our love even without him
and what does justice for jamal look
like
what do you want to see happen
actually um it is kind of
long story and long way as the mandala
said
in the history sometimes uh getting
justice or seeking just
justice take time but i don't
know actually uh this road until when
or what we we get justice in the end of
the road
but i don't think what will happen in
the future but i'm doing my turn
i'm doing my best and i i feel that
i have a big responsibility as a human
being and
and one day we will get justice together
and you will see that
i believe right and
jamal was a was achieved so much uh
in his life um but obviously he made a
lot of powerful enemies did you ever
feel in danger because of his work
no i didn't feel any danger
we were talking about this here i asked
him
and he told me uh the same
there is no worry about our life and the
security or
scare or something like that i wasn't
known that
actually uh the kind of
enemies against jamal
i wasn't know any um
any real dangerous
uh for for his life or for
i wasn't know these daytimes i i
i i know about uh saudi
more when jamal died
when you think of jamal how do you think
of him what
what image comes to your mind what sort
of man was he
yes i i miss jamal as
as a person as a journalist i
i miss him or i i wonder
when i when i feel something very
incredible or good i want to share with
him
i i miss him his voice and he was um
actually um very
um very different person for me like a
wisdom man
and the intellectual part
was very
pretty or or different for me and
i i feel a lot of good things uh
sometimes when i feel bad um i remember
him
directly and it will be it made it made
me
more comfortable more peaceful
we're sorry for your loss and we thank
you for joining us here at dw
uh tj jengas thank you so much
you